hey everybody and welcome to
wild ride with stevo oh boy did we laugh
really hard on this episode and i
revealed something uh that's pretty
embarrassing for me
okay and travis told a crazy story about
knoxville
let's get into it ladies and gentlemen
travis pastrana
yeah dude what what's up steve good to
see you bud good to see you too man i
want to introduce my co-host scott
randolph what's up dude
how you doing good coming from off
camera you'll hear the voice of the very
gorgeous paul briskey
what's up dude awesome yeah dude
so thanks for doing this man um you just
did uh
the big stunt in annapolis huh how
recent was that
uh yeah just uh actually about two weeks
ago so it was been pretty cool i mean
ken block
um you know was a friend for a while
started out as a sponsor
uh with dc shoes and then became a good
friend and we both were teammates at
subaru and then he went on to ford
became my biggest rival
uh started gymkhana just basically
having fun in his his car and
um he took it to like the next level of
kind of
like drifting all-wheel drive and
awesome locations and more horsepower
than has ever been in there
and uh he kind of was like all right
let's see let's just give you a shot so
um you know needed a good location
picked annapolis maryland which is my
hometown
all the roads and all the the jumps and
the the crossings that i always wanted
to do but
could never legally do uh we got the
cops on our side and uh politicians
supported us even though
uh some of the towns people were a
little like are you sure a thousand
horsepower subaru ripping around uh
historic annapolis brick roads and uh
dude it was awesome right how long does
it take you to get clearance for that
like
when's the idea come about and then for
a whole year
you were working on it yeah a whole year
yeah coba didn't help because all the
schedules kind of like we had to be
there when no one else was really there
the boat shows
i mean annapolis is awesome it's got um
you know the naval academy it's got all
the military
all the motorheads guys that love loud
noises and guns and then
you've got the sailors um so you kind of
have
both worlds there that uh that kind of
collide but uh no we we had a lot of fun
and
um we know most of the the firefighters
and the cops and all the guys that
didn't make it in motocross uh all went
military so
um definitely had a lot of backing that
way uh but just trying to clear it to
convince all the locals that i wasn't
going to drive the car right through
their shops
which almost happened a few times but
rather be lucky than good i always say
nice yeah i'm sorry i did hear you say
that but i was just looking at you and
i'm like man we're the same age but
you're just so much cooler than i am
dude
no one has ever said that about me crazy
yes
cool man um
i i went to high school with this buddy
his name is franz and he lives in
maryland
and of all the people i've known since
high school i would say franz and i
are dudes who like we're able to
make careers out of doing what we what
we love what we want
and what what franz does is builds rally
cars
oh really pretty rad did did we meet him
on tour
i'm sure yeah uh-huh at the the the
draft house in arlington
that's right we had it we had dinner
franz was on your skate team no on each
other
yeah i um so in any case shout out to my
buddy he makes rally cars but the real
question is
do you even drift bro
no honestly did this was the hardest
thing because
i basically subaru came to me and said
what do you want out of a car
and i said i want to shatter he'll climb
records i want an unlimited open car
give me the most downforce possible give
me a wing that i can actually fly it
so like you know usually for jumping a
vehicle you know a semi truck and a bus
and a motorcycle they all jump about the
same
but depending on the takeoff angle it
matters if the the vehicle's front and
low or front and high
and i wanted to go for a 300 foot jump
by the house
um just it was just basically a hill a
natural hill that you could jump after
you hit it about 100 miles an hour and
we did the calculations on this uh this
app for an iphone that said you had to
hit it about 135
so i hit it at 138 and we forgot to
calculate the downforce
oh came up short broke pretty much i
mean
i thought i broke my back the whole car
should have broken in half i bounced
another 150 feet down the backside of
this hill
um so yeah matt's not really my strong
point but
uh this car was absolutely awesome
but it had so much downforce that
actually made it more difficult
to drift i got the the most traction the
most power i mean first gear idles at
like 70 miles an hour
and then ken's like okay you got to do
some backing in around this little tight
areas and
going around tires and trash cans i'm
like no this this thing's made for going
150 mile an hour up a
one lane road in a mountain you know i
might have gone the wrong direction with
the build but it's going to be
sweet when we get it for racing that's
cool jesus
when you say uh buy the house this is
like
your nitro circus compound basically
right
though the world calls it pastrana land
i just i just call it home
yeah okay pastrana land and and i
remember
uh our jackass director who also
directed your uh nitro circus mtv show
he told me that the
like what do you call the uh air
when they helicopter people to the
hospital what do they call that they're
called lifelike
yeah yeah yeah the people who fly the
helicopters for the hospital
like they know exactly where your house
is like
all they yeah but to be fair most of the
people that go into that
that uh most of the pilots around here
they're all
friends and if you're into doing
dangerous stuff or i shouldn't say
dangerous i mean not like
back ass dangerous where you guys just
like intentionally
like this is gonna suck like you know
right
i mean you know that takes more balls in
my opinion like i always
naively think that i'm gonna land all
the stupid [ __ ] that i try
um where we usually don't but at least
we think we do
uh but at the end of the day like all
the military guys around here i mean my
best friend growing up was a navy and
ended up being a navy seal
until a couple years back and um they're
all pilots
and military and uh guns and shooting
and skydiving and
so if you're in the police or you're in
firefighters or you're flying anything
around this area chances are
we grew up together so it's uh you know
and and plus we had
dur uh yeah what was it we called it uh
i think black wednesday it was a really
bad day for us we had uh three
life flights the same day during when we
were we were young and dumb and um
filming
for one of the first nitro circus uh
dvds
um we put a thousand dollars on the win
and we sent three people that had
well more than a thousand dollars worth
of uh medical bills but it was totally
worth it
jesus um when so nitro circus started
way before it was an mtv show i remember
when uh i was in rehab
with a roommate of mine was it was just
going crazy about oh dude nature circus
these dvds man oh dude you gotta check
it out
and uh pretty shortly thereafter it
ended up that uh
nitro circus became an mtv show with
jeff tremaine
um but when did the nitro circus start
so
nitro circus was born uh pretty
organically through me getting injured
getting bored having pastrana land if
you will out back
and having the best guys in the world
wanting to learn
um tricks wanting to learn backflips and
we had
kind of because freestyle was really new
i mean i mean didn't even go in the x
game as far as motocross until 1999.
so i already had kind of racing
sponsorship and
kind of a way to pay for uh my
fun which was freestyle motocross so
kerry hart had the first foam pit
um but he didn't let a lot of guys kind
of ride it um where i had a phone pit
and i was like yeah come on out let's
see what we got
um so everyone would come here and learn
stuff so i was 18
19 20 years old and um i got a
camera from greg godfrey uh who was i
mean he worked as a key grip untouched
by an angel and he just wanted to be a
producer and then he realized that
you know i just like riding dirt bikes
and if i could film
dirt bike stuff that'd be great but he
couldn't get any riders to go out to the
desert and
go places so he called me up he's like
hey can you get the riders to go do this
stuff
and i'll film it all and we'll pay for
it all and
you know no one got paid but we all got
to do these awesome trips and then
you know we had video to show for it and
sponsors were stoked um
so every time i got hurt i just had a
camera i mean white balance wasn't set
the
nd filter i didn't know anything about
anything i just you know sony 2000
little hand camera that thing was was i
was worked and the footage was
the film quality was horrible but the
actual content
kind of got like uh i mean not a jackass
following but it was a pretty good
following for just a bunch of rednecks
riding dirt bikes so we were
we were stoked and then uh when evil
knievel um
you know when he passed away we got a
call from giant knoxville actually
knoxville called um matt hoffman
and huffman put him in touch with me
he's like hey what can you do we got a
24 24-hour takeover
of mtv what can you do and i sent him
like a 30-page list he's like he called
me up he's like hey
can you do any of this i said i don't
know we'll try it all and a week later
we were fishing a show on mtv
yeah and and i suppose in between there
for the evil knievel thing
dickhouse which is uh jeff truman johnny
knoxville
spike jones they were making a tribute
to
evil knievel and that was when knoxville
uh broke his wiener that is that is
accurate
you know it's really kind of
foreshadowing he uh
he can't ride like but literally when
you say someone can't ride you like oh
he was acting like he couldn't ride that
no like the man he is the worst
motorcycle ride i've ever seen in my
life
and we had to like bump start him in
second gear and i was like just pin it
when you hit the bottom
he's like look is this gonna hurt i'm
like yeah it's gonna suck you'll be
lucky enough to break something he's
like as long as i don't break my dick
sure enough right down on the handlebar
to the urethra
well i remember uh it being described to
me that you said
because he was gonna knock so that was
the bit the as a tribute to evil knievel
he was gonna try to recreate
the double backflip which at that point
had been pulled by nobody
but you travis pastrana right like in
competition
you're the only one to do a double
backflip so knoxville says i'm gonna do
the same thing i'm gonna do the double
backflip and uh they said that you told
him
that's great go for it but whatever you
do
just don't let go of the bike because if
you let go of the bike
it's gonna it's it's gonna leave you
in a vertical fashion which means it's
going to come back down and land on you
and that's what you don't want so
so make sure you hold onto the bike and
knock some goes flying up and the
[ __ ]
first thing he does is let go of the
fly's the bike in the air and it comes
right back down on the land the bike
landed on his deck and broke his urethra
and he had a [ __ ]
catheter tube down his dick for
for a [ __ ] date i think he kept that
as a badge of honor
for way longer than he needed it dude
knoxville's the only one
i don't even think not that it was that
long ago but i don't think he'd get away
with this today and i know
nobody else on the face the earth could
ever get away with what he did we're on
southwest flight
you know the story travis is about to
tell his killer
and i'm going to tell you something that
probably nobody in their right mind
would ever say out loud
for years i have worn only
boxers that are basically plaid dark
color and the reason for that i've
struggled with skid marks
okay and that's because wiping your butt
with toilet paper doesn't do a good job
it ends up with your butthole being
itchy
and then you want to scratch it when you
scratch it
your your underwear gets
skid marks okay and that's why i go with
dark underwear that doesn't show
skid marks but it's not a problem for me
anymore man
because i use a bidet on my toilet
and i've said this before this is my
favorite product
that i've ever promoted on the podcast
okay
it's called hellotushi and
you get it at hellotushy.com
of course if you go to hellotushy.com
you get a much better deal but what is
it and how does it work
it's a big day right when you get done
taking your sloppy
dump you twist this little knob right
here and
blasts your [ __ ] and it blasts it
like a
pressure cleaner it makes it so perfect
and
clean and then when you wipe there's
nothing there to make a skid mark with
so you need this thing i'm telling you
it's my favorite
and how are you going to get it you're
going to go to hellotushy.com
stevo and you're going to get 10 off
your order
so get 10 off your order at
hellotushy.como
now let's hear about knoxville um
four rows in front of him and he had a
catheter that made it that far
and i'm sound asleep my mouth wide open
up there
he puts the catheter over top of my
shoulder
everyone's giggling he like literally
goes back four rows
people he doesn't know and they're like
oh that's knoxville this is gonna be
great
and he pisses on me in a plane from four
rows back
regular commercial southwest flight i
wake up
everybody's laughing i'm thinking how
did he get away with this
and and i was pissed on so at 30 000
and he had the bag strapped around his
ankle he called it his lemonade stand
wait how long did he have this catheter
dude he kept that thing for
[ __ ] years man five years
years it happened and when did that
happen 2008
yeah yeah i know he had it for at least
a year and a half and i i'm i'm with you
i don't know i think you just like the
pranks you could pull with it
i mean what do you do you got to keep
taking that thing in and out or do you
just leave it in
i don't know taking it out and putting
it back in i think is the
bad part of it like once it's in it's
not so bad
i i had a buddy's dad who had a catheter
in but like when you put the catheter in
i think it blows up to like a balloon
inside to like keep it in there
and he came to in the hospital bed he's
like what the [ __ ] and he tried to pull
it out and the balloon was up
and it just wouldn't go out just because
he came to
um yeah i had a buddy i mean you know
the um
i might not want to identify the person
but remember the the
uh murder ball i know who you're talking
about
yeah not not zupan but there there's
another another guy and we were partying
together
he's another guy you know all the murder
ball was uh
these this uh sport for
like para athletes like uh paraplegics
yeah like um paralyzed guys and this one
guy was hanging out with partying
and and uh he's like oh dude can you
help me with my catheter
right he's all hammered he's got to pee
and i'm like all right
you know i'm a bro and i i i grabbed his
wiener
i put the catheter really yeah that's
nice of you
yeah and i was like hey dude no big deal
man i'm cool like that i'm very secure
with myself
so how do you get a catheter in there i
would it like do you kind of have to
hold it and like i mean you spit on it
shut
up you gotta get it wet
these guys are i'm a little i'm a little
concerned about that because they do
have use of their arms they're playing
that's a good question i don't know
that's [ __ ] hilarious dude
that's funny oh my god okay so knoxville
breaks his dick next thing you know
you're
you're pitching a an mtv show he's like
knoxville wanted help too
i don't know
and uh let let me go into the worst pit
the world's
worst pitch ever can you help me with my
catheter
well i went in with knoxville and
tremaine we had done a lot of pitches
and always got
kind of pushed aside and nothing went
through yeah okay yeah sure we'll call
you uh-huh sure whatever
well we went in with knoxville and
tremaine now knoxville goes in
and he's got a bunch of wicks attached
to big old
huge things of duct tape but the wicks
are like it's a live wick that he was
lighting on fire so he walks into mtv
lighting wicks fire in the hall long
wicks so we're like you know
20 seconds long and he's throwing these
uh these wicks they just go into
duct tape and he's throwing them and
everybody i mean these poor interns and
people
everyone's dropping their phones
computers are flying off desks people
are diving
they're thinking that knoxville being
knoxville is actually dropping like
you know these huge things of cherry
bombs everywhere it's going to explode
and then the whole office is diving on
the floor and he's laughing nothing goes
off because it's just wicks attached to
nothing
so we go in there everyone's kind of
already a little uneasy but everyone
knows that you know knoxville's in there
pitch another show which you have to
remain
we go in and you know i've done some
fairly good pitches before i was
you know fairly articulate with how
we've we've worded things and
they said okay so what's this show about
and uh
knoxville points to germany and jeff
goes all right
all right all right so um
picture this it's like jackass
but they don't do drugs
okay so i'm like that's your whole bit
that is your pitch no video no anything
a month later we had a show on mtv so
that's so funny
and uh i remember i was newly sober
and they said hey man can be uh on the
nitro circus show
you know we're shooting something in
california and
my question is was there ever a cameo
from somebody a guest appearance on
nitro
circus and the person was a bigger [ __ ]
than i was
when i was on nitro circus
you know what's interesting i'm gonna go
with no
i'm gonna go wait what happened really
interesting
you would volunteer you were like i'm in
you just didn't want to so nitro circus
it's all about like you actually have to
do the stunt
whereas i feel jackass is just hit go
fall off a cliff or jump obviously you
know what i mean like down the hill
gravity
bulls like once you say go you're in
well you had control of the the throttle
right
and you just wouldn't go fast enough to
make it worthwhile but you don't have
control of a bull
or a dynamite or bees or guns and i
realized that that's what your guys
stick was that
you just you committed to doing
something and then you didn't want to
be the one that had to hurt yourself i
do i think that you've just about nailed
it and that's a problem
like across the boards when you when you
have to do something it's so much easier
to like close your eyes and stay still
and wait for something awful to happen
then i disagree
knoxville goes balls are a win-win i'm
like no
if it doesn't hit you the footage is
unusable and if it hits you you get hit
by a bull
how is this a win-win situation because
when you get hit in the nuts you want
your eyes closed and i'm like there's no
[ __ ] way i'm closing my eyes waiting
for that i have to have my eyes closed
why because otherwise i'll flinch
[Laughter]
okay so when i was on the nitrous circus
the only
[ __ ] thing i was trying to do was
going like a two foot tall
if two like knee knee high like a knee
high
jump ramp like the kind of [ __ ] jump
ramp that i pushed up against the wall
to ride my skateboard up the wall yeah
like [ __ ] knee high and i just got to
ride a motorcycle
off a two foot [ __ ] jump ramp landing
in dirt mind you
and i could not bring myself to go off
of a two-foot jumper why
i don't know dude i don't like it
so wait what would you do like just veer
to the side or stop short
i think i would veer to the side i would
lay it down i would kind of like
i don't know i can't even remember but
it was awful dude like this so that's
probably just wouldn't let it happen
we have confirmation from travis
pastrana i was the biggest [ __ ] on
nitro circus
ever which is a little bit of a of an
honor
it's something hey travis the first
episode of nitro circus
was that when your dad jumped off the
boat
am i right on that so yeah we went down
to panama i wasn't the first episode but
um
yeah he so my dad always wore like just
cut off jeans
and he went down there in dc hooks them
up with these uh you know these big old
board shorts and he's stoked and
plus he's a lot older now he jumped out
of the boat so we're driving
and he's yelling at us hey come on you
you [ __ ] basically jump out jump
we're like dad we're going
90 we're not jumping out of the boat
he's like ah
[ __ ] jumps out the boat well he lands
in
one he's old too we're going 90. yeah
and all the piece of junk boats that we
have back home we had like you know
checkmates and stuff maybe like 65
70. that 20 mile an hour hits so he goes
in
and it rips his so he does the splits
when he lands please
he can't do the splits and um he
shatters his pelvis
starts bleeding out now he's my dad's
drill sergeant the marine corps he
doesn't
doesn't you know ever let anyone see him
in pain
so he swims back to the boat and he gets
on he
pulls himself up broken pelvis bleeding
out we didn't know it
and he just kind of sits on the back for
a while and i said dad are you okay
he said nope no one's
and everyone's kind of dying and uh like
hey you want to you want a pain shot or
you know because one of the doctors was
on just saw and i'm kind of seeing them
kind of go white
and uh dad goes yep i looked over i'm
like holy [ __ ] he is dying like i've
never seen him take so much like he'll
take advil but he doesn't believe in
pain meds he doesn't believe in like
anything and i'm like man he just took a
shot and he'd never
if you ever ask him if he's hurt he says
no i'm like i really think he's dying i
said hey dad you want to go back uh
back on shore he's like i need to go to
the hospital you know
i whenever you guys have done this i
didn't get hospital
um so they're kind of going around i'm
like you know hey guys let's not sit
back you know
it's pretty rough out in panama canal we
head back by this point he's pretty
white
and uh but he's still you know so he
gets up he walks not well mind you
but he he walks you know doesn't make
too much of a face broken pelvis
bleeding out
walks to shore sits down and we take
back off going
uh when he passes out on the on the on
the shore uh
goes to it and basically they put him in
shock trauma
uh two surgeries later uh gave him blood
for two days
and we had to go film the next gig in
jamaica
so we fly out and not a single person on
his whole level of
the hospital it was a john hopkins
hospital he's a real nice place but he
goes
my dad's singing when he got back he
goes man yes i showed up
the people at mcdonald's spoke english
he goes i got approached
by ten call women that all spoke english
he's like not a single person those
educated players down there spoke any
english
i woke up two days later had no idea how
i got there
why i was there had surgery got freaking
bags of blood attached
and you [ __ ] left me they said you
were gonna be fine anyway we have a good
good family relationship there and uh he
he hadn't done anything stupid since
so you're so he did it was his last
thing
he didn't remember the actual accident
you're telling me that
he he lost all memory of all of it like
he was
he was pretty much dead like he uh he
bled
bled out so he took him took him three
days to get back to where he was
conscious again
how do you bleed out when it what did he
eternal internally
uh yeah artery so basically when you
shatter your pelvis uh the
um the femoral arteries right there
evidently but yeah so he bled
blood like we had actually similar
injuries so he bled two thirds of his
blood volume out that's
same as i did when i was like 14. so was
that when you severed your spine
yeah so he did half of what i did he did
one side where i did
both both sides of the side joint you
passed out too right
yep well i passed out right away he's a
little tougher it took a bit longer to
pass it out
that was when you crashed into a tree
when you were no no i just didn't go
fast enough i landed short on a on like
120 foot jump
oh my god now we've had about a number
of uh
you know professional skateboarders we
asked
danny way ryan shackler tony hawk
actually
hasn't had that in many like grievous
certain injuries and surgeries i don't
think but uh
but sheckler and anyway absolutely how
do you think you stack up
uh next to danny way or ryan sheckler
for having surgeries i think both of
them have had multiple
knee surgeries like shoulders elbows
wrists all of it
so if you look at bmx uh you know you
got like
evil knievel the pioneer uh and then you
got bmx you have matt hoffman
and skate you have danny way and kind of
in in moto rally now
that's kind of my like yeah the just the
the people that just
now that we threw caution to the wind
but we're like yeah
yeah it'll work um and then kept getting
up and kept pushing i mean
probably the the only one i don't have
topped of the current list has to be
matt hoffman that guy
yeah dude he is the baddest dude living
on the face of the earth today hands
down without a doubt
um you know tony he goes about stuff
very methodically he loves what he does
but he skates
he still skates pretty much every day
that's a guy that i mean
he's got to be in his 50s right i don't
mean too
yeah so tony's in his 50s still doing
tricks that no one else has ever done
but he doesn't crash a lot he's he's you
know he's very calculated that way where
a guy like danny's like yeah i'm going
to jump the great wall of china
how do you build up to that you know
you're just kind of like ah
yeah right so i've had
35 operations and i'm 37 years old so
i'm crushing it i was actually i had 34
operations when i was 32.
so i'm definitely going the right
direction here nice yeah
i love the way you broke that down that
that uh bmx is matt hoffman skating's
danny way
and moto is you and you're all following
in the footsteps of evil knievel
yeah i mean it's beautiful it's perfect
and i think that that probably sounds
right because
matt hoffman is the most physically
reconstructed human being i think
in any sports and and probably even
outside
you'd have to have like really bad luck
with car accidents
to approach matt hoffman's level of
surgery
but matt finally gets he gets both
shoulders he gets his back he gets his
knees he gets his ankle a wrist
everything done at once he's like
literally he's like 10 months where he
can't do anything
and he's getting back going and he's in
yeah he goes i was going through
a stop sign and me he got run over by a
tractor trailer like a
semi truck ran a red light and he was
back broke everything again
now not to jump in someone else's story
and you guys gotta gotta get him on for
sure but
this is the gnarliest footage i've ever
seen so
it's uh dennis mccoy and
uh matt hoffman and it's just them in
the middle of oklahoma
um on this quarter pi or half pipe and
they're trying to do an over under cross
or something they got a camera
well uh they head head-on collision
um one of them's knocked out matt's got
a broken like
he's busted all up dennis has a broken
back and they're laying there
and it's just both of them kind of uh
unconscious for a little bit and then
you see them both kind of come too and
they're both kind of like figuring out
what's going on
and then it's matt uh military crawling
over to the golf cart to
to jump in the golf cart completely
broken to go get help so um
you guys that's probably the gnarliest
thing i've ever seen and it's all on
justice gopro sitting there
oh my god dude and he still he still
rides every day
hi guys that guy's amazing it's it's
absolutely unbelievable
yeah do you have any tricks coming up
are you like after you accomplish
something big like that are you like all
right let me get
or do you have stuff in your mind that
you that you still want to work on
i want to know do you have a video game
because
it seems like uh tony hawk pro skater
you know like is there has there been a
motocross video game or
uh yeah back in the early 2000s uh dave
mira and i both
sews dave mirror pro bmx and travis
jenna um
promote across basically under the same
activision label as
as uh tony but uh tony's i mean that
that actually that video game might have
been what took action sports
um to the the mainstream i mean that and
x games all coming out i mean it was it
was
huge i mean everybody to this day still
knows tony hawk and a lot of it is
from the video game which is really
really cool right but no we haven't
haven't done a lot
honestly i just think i'm that guy that
loves
to ride my dirt bike i love to drive i
love to do stuff that's never been done
um as far as like figuring out tricks
and ramps and
uh working with airbag landings and just
that innovative stuff
okay let me ask you about this um we
we're i'm planning just for my own and
it's something i wanted to do for the
longest time
is to uh dress up as a crash test dummy
and just drive a car into a wall like uh
to to to
test the airbag i know that that doesn't
really fit with my
like you know i i don't know how to go i
think i can
i think i'll pull it but uh what what do
you think about that and logistically
how uh did the car were thinking about
using
is uh from where when did we get it like
2015 2015. ford fusion and we just got
to make sure that the airbag
blows up how do we know that the airbags
are still good from when we bought it in
and the easiest way to get the airbags
to go off
is just to get over a jump and the best
part is you unhook your airbag
but you don't unhook the passenger's
airbag so you're laughing you go over a
jump
and it lands on the front end a little
bit and pushes down the front end and
they're laughing all of a sudden
boom straight to the back of the seat
all right
yeah that's not my style yeah i mean you
could be the passenger i'll take you
over jump
yeah maybe we can have uh uh travis
write it i [ __ ] hate that but
uh but see i feel like there's a way
bigger idea
here where you get like a car company to
sponsor it and it's like
sort of an ad for them like we don't
want to use a crash test dummy so we're
going to use a human to show you how
safe our car
is and then we believe in our safety so
much
around here a crash test dummy
yeah yeah that's pretty good yeah i
think that there
there could be a big one there um i
gotta ask you
uh are your night terrors getting any
better
i i heard i said we can cut that out if
you want but
i was just i was so curious about that
we're gonna learn all about
night terrors but do you know what's
even scarier
when your girl goes into your drawers
and finds your
bush out of control and by bush
gentlemen i mean your pubic hair
are you grooming it properly like me
because if you're not thank god for
manscaped
that's what i use to keep my balls nice
and trimmed
keep my package looking good and
speaking of package
manscaped is ready for the holidays with
the perfect
package 3.0 that's the manscaped perfect
package
3.0 it is everything that you need to
keep yourself
groomed and in tip-top shape to get
plenty of action with the ladies
so gentlemen how are you going to get
this for yourself this holiday season
you're going to go to manscaped.com
stevo and that's going to get you 20 off
your order
and free shipping that's 20 off your
order
and free shipping if you go to
manscaped.com
stevo telling you it's important to look
good
like me now let's talk about night
terrors
well so we i was in vegas and i got this
wait what are night terrors i guess
scott scott
you know it was was poking around the
internet and uh
doing some research on you he learns
that you have what's called
night terrors and what what does that
even mean
um it's a good question kind of like you
ever seen a sixth sense like the
i see dead people kid yeah so
everyone has a lot of there's all
different types or whatever but i feel
like i'm fully awake
um and obviously i'm not awake but
i feel like i am i'm in pla wherever i
went to sleep and you wake up and um
a lot of weird stuff um for instance i
knocked out my tooth
uh there was basically a
big dog uh chasing me and i woke up and
i'm running i dove down the
steps and as i'm in the air diving down
the steps i'm like
there's no dog in my room and i busted
out my front tooth
uh so that's the only tooth i lost was
actually uh from from a night terror
uh you know basically
see stuff in the in the fire uh when the
fire is not on
um it's it's a little strange um so
interestingly enough when you're
traveling a lot and you run down a lot
you're
run down on b vitamins uh b vitamins is
what's your energy but that also creates
melatonin
so melatonin is what helps keep you
asleep so a lot of times if you're
really run down
you'll see a lot of the military guys
have it a lot of action sports people
have it
uh sheckler actually has night terrors
which was really funny because
i took off yelling screaming running one
way this is a long time ago sheckler was
yelling screaming running the other way
and my roommate you normally uh
chris haynes who normally didn't care if
he heard me running he's like i
he was like out the door and underwear
like what's going on we're like oh just
night terrace he's like well if just one
of you i wouldn't have been so concerned
two of you all running from opposite
rooms in different directions so does
that does that mean that
that it happens while you're asleep is
it like a
dreaming and you're having a nightmare
kind of thing or uh yeah for the most
part so like for instance uh my one of
the first times i had a night terror i
was like
12 years old and um you know i was in a
hotel room with my parents out in vegas
and they woke up and the doors open
my feet were all bloody i had run about
a half mile
across the desert from from our motel 6
just in my underwear barefoot full
sprint before i noticed that uh you know
that i was dreaming or what i was
running from
so i go back to a couple years ago
um i was on an airplane and it was
i fell asleep while i was on the runway
and this is what i'm most afraid of is
like this
you know one of those those uh agents
are going to be on and i'm going to be
running towards the cockpit luckily i
was running towards the back of the
plane
and not towards the front of the plane
screaming at the top of my lines
running as fast as i can in the back of
the plane we're still on the runway
and they're like everyone please sit
down so we can take off and i had to
walk
back past every one of these people i'm
sorry my dad
was like what the hell just happened
so i try not to fall asleep on planes
anymore although the night chairs are
getting better
uh but i had an awesome hotel room in
vegas and um
i was about to go to sleep with all the
doors open and i was like man this is a
bad idea cause i'm gonna
wake up jumping off the side of the
building so i try to double latch all
the doors and try to make sure that i
wake up before i do anything stupid is
there any footage of you having night
terrors
no no and if there was i would
definitely not tell you
[Laughter]
oh my god it's crazy that you mentioned
uh vitamin b
i think it's it's uh when i was doing
all my nitrous oxide
i i would have these crazy [ __ ]
hallucinations like super
super involved like you know i'm seeing
stuff happening that's not really
happening and hearing voices voices out
all the rest of it and uh i ended up
doing some research as to like what the
[ __ ] is going on with it and they said
that
that inhaling nitrous oxide like as much
as
as as that reduces your vitamin b
and leads to these crazy hallucinations
so maybe there's a connection there with
night terrors
yeah i think it could be uh
like basically your ptsd or whatever
because a lot of military guys get it
and whatever
and i'm sure you you have some uh you
know injuries head injuries
or you know don't do drugs i think is is
a good one
were you you were researching like why
you're having terrors
because of nitrous oxide i mean i never
considered it terrors i mean i i was uh
steve loved it he wanted to find out how
to replicate that
i did love it but uh my experience was
that i entered the spirit world on some
level
and that i was interacting with
angels and demons so there was like
super dark [ __ ]
but there was also like really cool like
wonderful
like loving stuff you know um
have you ever told a story on the
podcast when you were doing so much
whatever
that some dude came in and like took a
bong load it was like
yeah i think i've told that story plenty
i love that um
why not so what about what about head
injuries man i mean like uh
where you are do you think with
concussions um
well it's actually pretty interesting
had a great opportunity um
to basically go down to uh to texas
and it's one of the the top kind of
military uh so i don't know you ever
heard of marcus latrell
uh the lone survivor mark wahlberg
played him in the movie but
his brother his twin brother morgan um
was actually kind of uh he was a seal as
well got in a bad helicopter crash
uh they said he'd never walk again and
he came back on multiple tours
um awesome awesome dude uh so
he got together with through the boot
campaign um which is basically trying to
help
guys that come over with cte and ptsd
and everything to
uh mostly military uh to heal up and to
be able to
kind of get back doing what they love to
do so they're not depressed and that
kind of stuff
but he came to nitro circus and
basically
just saw the injuries that we were
having and said hey uh take your three
biggest head injury people and come on
down
um we got the cooper clinic um down in
texas and we've put together the best
head trauma doctors uh from around the
world to basically come out here and and
we can
do the best we can of assessing you i
went with jim to champ
who's had quite a few head injuries as
well as james foster
uh same we've all hit our heads a lot
and we went down there just to see what
the long term was and when
what they were thinking and you know
there's still a lot that people don't
understand about the head but what's
really the biggest takeaway for me was
you know boxing
um even football where you know you
always talk kind of the same way you hit
the same spot
um you know soccer uh you take headers
yes
all the time you're always doing in the
same kind of area um
that was what causes cte um
more than than even a major you can have
one major head injury
obviously have effects for the rest of
your life but for the most part
if you don't hit the same spot over and
over again it's not even having a full
concussion
it's you know when you get your bell
rung a little bit and if you have your
bell rung again and again and again and
again in the same spot
before it has a chance to heal that's
what causes the brain damage and long
lasting effects so
to be honest motocross is a pretty good
sport because usually when we hit our
head hard enough to be knocked out we're
really broken
we don't have a chance to get back on
for a while so right that's kind of nice
i think i think what what you're saying
is uh
the repetition a lot of little the the
the uh
the accumulation of a lot of little
uh boxing or like being a lineman just
constantly or like coming out on stage
every night and breaking
[ __ ] beers on your head yeah
then when i got sober i'd go on tour and
i would come out on stage breaking cans
of club soda on my head
[ __ ] [ __ ] idiot i would do that
and then
and then at a certain point waking up in
the morning i'd get up and walk out of
bed like on a weird diagonal like
losing my balance like i'd be like man i
got to stop hitting my head
[Music]
like an idiot yeah and soccer that's a
good those headers like
i'm surprised people don't just get
knocked out sometimes from hitting those
it's no fun man i've played soccer and
you go head the ball that [ __ ] [ __ ]
hurts yeah it hurts even if it's not
even kicked that hard like sometimes it
comes from like 50 feet up and you're
hitting it yeah
i have a question i want to go back to
something actually like scott
called you like cool travis and you sort
of like shrugged it off like you don't
feel cool or like you'd think you're not
cool
is that like uh have you always felt
that way like sort of your uncool
i yeah i mean i really feel like i have
a good question
so much the double back flip i started
coming back around and everyone's like
oh i can't believe you wear a plaid and
then it was like
oh yeah you're cool and then now it's
like oh you're trying to catch that
trend it's already passed i'm like it's
not a trend man like i'm just me
and that's been the greatest thing
motocross like i was very fortunate from
a young age
to be good at what i did and it was it
wasn't a [ __ ] sport
you know moto like if you could do
motocross and you could
just eat [ __ ] and i was the first person
to
never quit to get back up i mean my dad
would kick my ass if i'd
stop for any reason he always goes if
you fall down you don't know if you're
broke until you get back up you're
broken
whatever you broke it'll fall back on
and you'll fall down on your face if
you're not
you'll figure it out and you'll get back
up you keep going so i was always kind
of that quiet shy kid and right around
the second or third grade
um i started getting a little bit of
credibility for being
you know kind of the best of my area the
best in you know the nation for
motocross and got a reputation for being
the
guy that huck the biggest jumps crashed
the most got up
quicker never complained and that
reputation
like i was 15 at the x games against
metal militia brian deegan all those
guys
you know world domination and you know
all trying to be cool
i at the time no tattoos no like i
didn't drink a single drop
alcohol until i was 22. now i've made up
for lost ground but you know i was
focused on uh i was focused on
being an athlete and i didn't care what
anyone thought was cool it didn't matter
to me
i wanted to be the best at what i did
and
just doing that gave me that respect i
could walk into any crowd
it didn't matter if it was you know
hell's angels or bible club
you know they'd be like oh dude yeah
you're that guy or you know or whatever
like and it was
it was kind of neat to be able to walk
in and out of
any realm and just be kind of
if not accepted at least respected um
for what you did so so no my job was
never it was always
kind of people obviously sponsor me so
it sells stuff
but i mean nitro circus was like metal
militia was the cool kids the nitro
circus was like you know the straight a
students that just really wanted to be
the best of what they did or
go the biggest we don't care like we
brought scooters into like the
mainstream
i mean scooter's obviously doing huge
and everyone's like no no scooters
i'm like kids doing awesome and pushing
themselves and it's helping our industry
hell yeah scooters and then r willie
best scooter
he switches over to bmx and wins he's
the winningest uh big air bmx rider of
all time and he's just a scooter kid so
it's like
yes this is great dude i [ __ ] love
our willy man
so after the mtv show then you make
like proper nitro circus the movie
and uh that one like the movie industry
i think is kind of
kind of weird where like it's the
highest stakes form of gambling
and uh the question is whether it's
going to be like
wide theatrical release at which point
you're gambling so much
but the nitro circus i feel like
that movie was probably probably a
pretty small budget right
like so we we went too big on our budget
greg godfrey um our producer was
convinced he's like this will be the
first
3d film that the 3d actually
is that's going to be what sells it so
we did triple the budget of what we
should have done for these brand new 3d
cameras which now cost
one tenth the price of what they did um
you know tremaine and knoxville kind of
told us they're like i don't think
you guys quite have that following it's
not a jackass jackass relates on all
levels
um action sports any anything that's a
skill
stunt once people see that it's a skill
stunt they just ex they don't understand
it so they just expect it to work
or if it doesn't work then they're just
like that guy's not good at what he does
as opposed to jackass where anyone can
relate to
um you know getting in a shopping cart
and going down a hill really fast
same thing nitro circus our biggest
stunts were the slip and slide where the
big wheels were the stuff that everyone
could relate to
but the problem with the film in my
opinion looking back on it
was that we were so scared shitless all
the way through
that we didn't have the camaraderie that
jackass did we were focused on doing the
biggest
best craziest stunts and doing them to
the best they possibly could have been
and we were so focused on that that we
forgot when you're making a movie
it's got to be fun it's got to be
exciting they have to actually feel
what we really felt it breaks my heart
to hear you describe
uh first off i think that
that you guys absolutely have crazy
camaraderie i don't think that that's uh
a valid criticism and no it it is
in my opinion because we had that off
off screen but it wasn't because we were
doing a 3d
film we didn't get to prolly like
everything that we filmed were the
stunts
so that movie the 3d film don't give me
wrong stunts were good and we had some
crazy stuff we had some good funny stuff
in there but at the end of the day
the camaraderie was everything that
happened off-screen so we just didn't do
a good job like you guys did
of capturing that to relate to the
general general audience and we
we kind of dumbed it down for the
audience when i think the audience we
got to give them more credit
like they're they're going to pick up on
stuff you don't explain it all out i'm
uh
very much not representative of like the
average american or
moviegoer or you know even like my own
audience i'm just not because
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] man i went to
the screening
before it came out and i was just like
oh my god [ __ ] nitro circus
hallelujah i enjoyed it so
much dude and you guys made a follow-up
to it right that
was that was the follow-up to it
was that a movie per se or was it
so the follow-up actually is what's
gonna be really funny
um it still hasn't actually got picked
up yet but that
i think it's better than the movie
because it basically showed
i mean greg godfrey spent a half million
dollars
on an ending that never got seen and
instead
he he wanted a parade but it was a gay
pride parade
i'm like greg we could do like the
hooters parade
or the bikini model tropics parade or
whatever
uh and it was just it was very very odd
and it was it was hilarious but it was
basically this movie that everyone came
on board
and everyone's like yeah the plot was
like what plot like greg godfrey kept
saying there was a script or a plot or
whatever okay yeah do your lines we're
like what why like what are you talking
about
no one gave us any direction we were
just doing stunts and then he tried to
put the whole thing together
at the end from what was in his head it
would have worked but he didn't explain
it to anybody
his vision so this we did kind of like
the
almost joking on ourselves like how can
you possibly raise five million dollars
to do a film
and have no idea three quarters of the
way through
what what are you even filming and i
just thought that was um
an attribute both to the fact that we
had had enough success that people
believed in us
and the fact that we still have no idea
what we're doing and somehow
it's kind of almost working most of the
time yeah
correct man that's a um
the the 3d movie like uh
let's say let's say we want to watch it
right now we go on itunes like uh
where is it where does it live yeah no
you can you can go
see it on itunes um i shoot i don't even
know i thought it came out on netflix uh
but i'm i'm not 100
sure so yeah but it's um it's still one
of the
one of the best um like itunes action
sports
uh films which was was pretty cool like
the audience that saw
it liked it the actual absolutely
[ __ ] loved it i loved it
well i appreciate it yeah we had we did
have fun despite being scared to death
the whole movie
and almost killing jim and tommy uh yeah
i was that was pretty good
yeah and then um the nitro circus
uh action figures was that the follow-up
to it
that was the next and that's that was
yeah so we had um we had nitro circus
like our dvd series
um and then we did uh through billy's
dvd series um then throwability's got
so nitro series got picked up on mtv and
through abilities got picked up on fuel
uh back when fuel was like that thing
you just turned on and it was always
had action sports and stuff before uh
the mma took over fuel
um so we had those two things and then i
wanted to get back to the old school
music
video like back to uh you know creatures
of habit and the old whiskey films and
just what i grew up on you know like
cky2k and you know kind of the batch of
the culture of
what made action sports uh so i came out
with action figures and we did an action
figures too
um i spent way more basically of my own
money making the film than we did then
we made from it
but for me it was totally it was awesome
just to be able to have an excuse to go
out there
with our friends in the backyard and at
the end of the day that helps kind of
keep the brand going and we so the first
action figures
we got uh joshian ended up doing a
triple backflip uh jed milton
uh and james foster were racing for a
quadruple backflip on a bmx bike
um those both got taken out of the film
because nycha said they were too big
to be in a music video so we
put them back in but it wasn't like they
got put on like uh
network television or whatever um but we
were able to do so much and move action
sports and airbags and
shoot i had probably six hundred
thousand dollars worth of investment in
how do you make a flat bag into a
landing bag and what's the best landing
bag and then we have you know
since that movie came out um all the top
uh
you know olympic federations for all
these different countries were basically
calling nitro circus
how do you keep these guys healthy what
do you do on this how do you do that
uh working with bag jump and it was
really uh even though
financially it didn't make a lot of
sense it was a really cool thing for
kind of the future of action sports and
something that i really enjoy doing i
mean it seems like there's a financial
like a a big business and and
like evolving in the this whole
bag technology yeah but i spent like
you know you said over a half million
dollars designing and making these bags
and figuring out what to work and not
work and now you can buy them for like
60 000
which is still expensive but you know
for for the amount of effort and work
that we put in but i think at the end of
the day
high tide floats all ships i want to
work with espn and the x games i want to
work with
you know obviously part of nitro in the
nitro world games for the big arab
action sports and
um you know you got all these x fighters
so with red bull and
um you know everybody wants to do their
own thing i think if everyone kind of
works together and figures out
how can we make this the safest we
possibly can
to give the riders the longest like the
longevity in the sports
but we have to keep progressing if we
don't progress
you know we're not gymnastics it's not
about pointing your toes and
trying to win olympic medals like i mean
i know skating's in the olympics and
stuff but at the end of the day
like i think still for skating like
video parts are still what i consider
sure like you go out and i yes skating
you can do it perfect once yes
competition that's great that's one
whole
side of it but the other side is what
can you do that no one else has ever
done how can you be creative how can you
make a video a part
that no one you know and that's what you
guys yeah and
the one thing we haven't touched on
which is like
probably the biggest uh you know the
biggest revenue stream i would imagine
is the nitro circus tour i mean you guys
routinely
have traveled the world like with
[ __ ]
humongous arenas the overhead for the
show has got to be absurd
but uh but the business of touring
arenas is is
probably pretty lucrative right the
business was great until koben
um right nitro is going to be very
different
um when this comes out because not only
i mean we had
60 shows uh canceled this year
so that's and not that this shows
they're not
really money makers but they keep
you know unfortunately had to lay off
uh you know quite a few people there's
just no like even the
the riders and trying to figure out okay
we're switching to youtube and we're
doing these side off events but
you know instead of everyone getting
paid x amount for a stadium show of you
know 30 000
down in um south africa we're doing
drive-in shows
where you know 1500 people show up and
you know it's
it's just not there's not the same
person
to pull from um or not purse but
funding if you will uh so it's really
been tough on the riders
uh it's been tough on the whole touring
um you know and what we're doing going
forward we don't know what
um kobe if they're gonna allow back you
know stadiums that we can fill up night
and night again or if there's gonna be
spacing so
um you know huge hit for our industry as
a whole but
it's helped all the writers be a little
bit more creative instead of saying okay
i'm just going to go on tour all the
writers have stepped back and say okay
now i have to make content
if i want to get paid i have to figure
out how to make
content daily content sure but at least
a couple big ones a month
um and you know nitro is doing our doing
our best to to reach out to the writers
and say okay
whether it gets one view or a million
views
um you know if you give us something
that's three to five minutes longer
we'll pay you x amount just because you
know riders are promised
you know 20 30 50 events a year
depending on
on on the rider and the scale so you
know you're never guaranteed that you
can always get hurt but it's
in the back your head you think okay i'm
gonna have this as a fallback well now
everyone's had to change a lot of guys
have gone to you know construction a lot
of guys in
uh australia working the mines trying to
figure out like
we realized right now that we are a
hobby and
how fortunate we are to be able to live
our
dream life um you know it's it's hope
it's been tough
when you talk about the content uh is
this at the nitro circus youtube channel
is that is that what we're promoting to
to get eyeballs on the content yeah so
nitro circus we really didn't have a
youtube channel for instance we i mean
there was one but we didn't put a lot
into it um but now we're saying okay
let's get the media house side of this
going like what can we do we've
had a bunch of events on uh basically
espn the ocho
uh but espn2 um because without x games
uh they've had a lot of world of x and a
lot of stuff that that they didn't have
content for
um so that's helped us get different
shows like we've been doing pit bike
racing and
basically every way we can have fun
because especially for a little bit
um we couldn't have more than a certain
amount of people around so a lot of the
um you know the bigger production
companies couldn't film but nitro we
could still
send a few gopros out and have the
riders film themselves at home do
whatever they're doing and
and help us manage our sponsorship
um through hey we can't do this event
but we can have this rider
do this and um you know find the guys
that fit best and that want to do that
that kind of
content and um you know our youtube
channel we're basically
we've had an amazing opportunity to
bring so many
um shows that we kind of pushed aside or
buried for a little bit
like the race to rebuild if you guys
have a chance to check this out
we basically went and when uh hurricane
maria
devastated puerto rico three riders
myself included
came out of retirement and raced the
biggest motocross race on earth
the motocross of nations for team puerto
rico then went down with all of our
construction buddies
um all the ramp builders all the welders
that we have that normally build ramps
and stuff
who all didn't really have a lot going
on we went down uh to puerto rico and we
put roofs on
four houses and rebuilt a couple
motocross tracks that were down there
and
um went to a school and donated a lot of
people helped uh
you know kind of uh helped us to to be
able to give back
to a territory of the us so stuff like
that that would
never normally have seen the light of
day um we got to to
document better and and uh try to try to
do the best we could during the time
the race to rebuild that sounds like a
good balance between
action and philanthropy
yeah you don't have to know anything
about motocross to like it
but my uh you know my five-year-old
daughter sat through the whole thing
because it does if you get a chance it's
uh
it's worth a watch and that lives on
so that lives on uh that's a great
question
he lives on google takes you the rest of
the way sorry fail
just look it up i'm sure you'll find it
i love it
i love it um [ __ ] man i gotta jump on my
psychiatrist call dude
that's the best ex that i've ever heard
i don't know
i gotta go to psychiatrists from 1101
right now [ __ ] man well uh okay let's
run let's quickly run through where
we're sending people
like uh we've got nitro circus on
instagram
it's a constant flow of epic [ __ ] that
i'm so i love following so everybody
follow nitro circus on instagram travis
pastrana on instagram
yeah just uh it's not he's not uncool
he's [ __ ] lovable a little dorky a
lot lovable
and uh and i'm gonna that's gonna be my
next i'm putting that on my instagram
i like it so hey be sure to check out
jim khanna but hey
for me you know what i i just want
people to go out there
to get off the video games to have some
fun to get outside
and freaking man get on your scooter get
on your bmx bike your dirt bike
that that's i'm passionate about that my
kids love that dude pump tracks bmx
tracks whatever you motocross tracks
go have some fun and get outside that's
cool i i [ __ ] love that dude
i i love that and uh oh our willy
he's our willy on instagram god he's
[ __ ] you gotta check it you gotta
check him out
i [ __ ] love him so much man um
all the nitrous circus right of wheels
wheels is an official nitro circus rider
right
he's unbelievable that dude backflip
360 in a wheelchair he just just threw
his arms
off yeah like a normal wheelchair not
like anything special just
awesome and he builds his own chairs
it's pretty cool that's right oh my god
so it's so great
um well hey brother [ __ ] thank you so
much for doing this man what an honor
and uh did i just i really appreciate
you man i'm a huge fan
well right back at you and i really
appreciate the opportunity to be on here
and uh look forward to
seeing more of your episodes coming up
soon man oh yeah dude thank you so much
travis
dude thank you guys well i hope you guys
laughed as hard as we did man because
god that was fun dude ah
here we are again you special people who
stuck around to the very end i want you
to know how much you mean to me
um let's let travis know that we enjoyed
this
what a good guy huh and um
what else man yeah i was that much of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] on nitro circus okay so
off my back
and we'll see you next week